remember how i was telling you i did my
metcon metabolic conditioning after i
yes like normal lifting so i've probably
been doing the reverse of that lately
really i don't know i would advising
because i'm super
warmed up i'm dripping with sweat yeah
and i just
and i feel really good and then i figure
maybe the opposite will happen
because we both know if you go with your
with your strength movements first
you take a little bit off your met
constrict right yeah if
if you do and so that way when you do
the metcon fresh you feel like superman
right because you
blasted your muscles out so i've been
doing the reverse though
when i'm doing the metcon type
first and then i just breathe it out and
then i get onto the heavy stuff
yeah and i dig it the only reason i say
i dig it
because you're savage like that but
consider
because those are two well it depends
depends on what kind of lifting you're
doing
so let's say if no well if you're
lifting like for strength or you know
muscle growth or whatever you should do
that first because
the results you seek are in line with
you having full energy
you lifting i i agree with you i
actually think you're correct
and the metcon isn't the result of the
metcon is for you to recover from
conditioning so you it's muscular
conditioning so
if you're tired going in that's more
conditioning you have to recover from
better exercise so it essentially but
hey if you want to reverse it give your
body some some
some stuff it's to yeah
i i completely agree with you and i've
only been doing this for
a couple months and i you know what it
was you know what it was one day i was i
wasn't gonna do like a metcon was pretty
strong
it was feeling good sure and then i got
done i said i need a little bit more
so i was like i'm just going to move
some you know something heavy
get my lift off and when i when i went
heavy i was like man that feels good
right now i'm all loose i'm all warm and
so now i've just kind of
started doing a little bit yeah and if
you get used to that then
it it'll start to be more and more
beneficial i used to i used to run on
the treadmill i used to do like three
and a half miles sometimes four miles
and then lift just because i didn't have
time and
every time i lift i would never feel
like running the you know the mile
afterwards i do it on a treadmill that's
right so i'd be like you know what i'm
gonna get the the running out of the way
then i'm gonna lift
yes and then i was like dang lifting is
it's kind of harder but i'd way
rather endure this discomfort when i'm
lifting than when i'm running on the
treadmill
but i did that for months and months and
months and then one day i didn't run i
was like
it was weird i was like stiff yeah so
you kind of get used to it but
either way i mean my original point is i
do the met now i do the metcon after i
lift
doing the metcon after that that has
been my standard for
so long right but you know how you're
saying do the metcon before you left or
or
you're just doing the metcon that day
it's easier yeah because you don't
you're not starting from lifting
yeah yeah but um anyway
my original point was the shroom tech so
if you're doing that kind of thing
after you lift when you're going into
the metcon you're gonna feel way better
you wanna hear something cool
so a lot of times people ask me what
is your workout right they want to know
reps sets weights
yeah right and that's cool of course um
and i haven't i haven't put it out there
for
well i'm i got a book i'm putting
together a book book
kind of thing actually not gonna be an
ebook it's gonna be a real book yeah
hardcover yeah
like a real legit book um
which means gonna take a little more
time but i'd rather do it
and do it right but what's interesting
is this is what's so cool
so people that people that listen to
podcasts and asking it have been
applying the basic principles
because i have never put i haven't put
out i don't think i put out a single
workout
i also people say what do you
actually eat right they want to know
what i had for breakfast lunch dinner
what i had for snacks whatever
yeah all i say is like oh you know i
mostly you know i i
low very low carbs i eat a lot of meat i
do a lot of protein i need a lot of fat
okay what do you do for workouts i get
up early in the morning i hit it hard
you know am i doing squats i'm doing
pull-ups i'm doing it just basic stuff
right i've put those
basic principles out there well there's
people
troopers that have been applying these
basic principles
and they're making incredible progress
in their lives they're getting stronger
they're getting
leaner they're getting in better shape
so it's
actually proven because i remember you
and i talked about this a long time ago
i said listen
it's more about the commander's intent
right the working house about the
commander's intent it's not about
i'm gonna tell you how many reps and
sets to do i'm going to tell you what
you want to
make happen right i'm going to tell you
where you want what where you want to be
at the end of this workout right
physically and mentally and
and people have been taking that and i
mean all kinds of people
they have lost 28 pounds i've lost 42
pounds
just from applying the basic principles
that i and
and so those will be consolidated in the
book so that people can follow them and
there'll be some other
good stuff in the book too basic
philosophy of
philosophy yeah yeah that is well that
was kind of a tangent on on it wasn't it
well i ate rightly so i think uh rightly
so
i think so it's consistent right which
which
actually kind of brings me to my point
the consistency is
probably the most overlooked fact even
though people know yeah you got to be
consistent we got it
but that's kind of everything because
everything else is variable like you can
you can there's a billion different
workers
by consistency do you mean
doing the same thing or you just mean
doing it every day getting in there and
doing it
yeah absolutely not skipping days weeks
you know getting off the horse you know
that kind of stuff
there's a million different workouts you
can do that will give you results
and there's a million different results
that you can you can kind of strive for
and get them because it's just so many
same thing with diet
like you can you know you people have
their rigid diet philosophy but the fact
is
that many different diets work i mean
there's
some basic principles you don't need a
bunch of sugar you don't need a bunch of
fast food you don't
you know the obvious things to avoid and
you can get results with many kinds of
data and i would go one step further
what you're talking about is consistency
in
in order to have consistency that
requires the distance
it does require the discipline so that's
the key factor
that is the key factor and when people
apply the discipline to their lives boom
right now everything becomes consistent
and that's their progress
so the books can come and the books can
talk about that
there you go